foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm your host Dave Ramsey
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones for you to call in
and talk about your life we'll talk
about you right in front of you the
phone number is AAA
825-5225 you jump in and we'll talk
Tristan's going to start this hour in
Indianapolis hi Tristan how are you
I'm great how are you Dave better than I
deserve what's up
um so I'm calling to get some advice on
our situation
my husband
my husband's making 80 000 a year we
have about 140 000 and just various
debts to get paid off our house we have
about 173 000 left on our house if we
were to sell
today in the market we can make about a
hundred thousand I guess my question is
should we do that to pay off some of
this debt you've got a hundred and forty
thousand how much was it in debt yeah
about 140 000 and we have two cars yeah
how much of that give me your car
breakdown
car is that like a like eleven thousand
okay and what's the rest of this mess
and then we have student loans and we
have a
a smaller loan that's like 11 or 12 000
that helped fix our crawl space the
student loans are the big chunk
Yes Yes mine especially how much is it
and how many kids do you guys have we
have three how old are they sorry I know
that's rapid fire
we have an eight-year-old a
five-year-old and a one and a half year
old
if it's me I have a couple questions
okay he's a nurse he's making eighty
thousand is were you working before kids
or have you always been a stay-at-home
mom
briefly
a second
um my paycheck essentially just would
pay for child care and it just wasn't
worth it for us so what was your career
um I mean just customer service type
gigs I worked at a gym front desk type
things you have a degree
I don't okay
and your husband's a nurse okay is there
anything that you can I
let me rephrase that question I think
that there are things that you can also
do to earn money from home when you have
time because at the end of the day the
equation here is we've got to get the
income up I wouldn't sell the house to
get a hundred thousand dollars if that
was your initial question
um I think that you guys need to work
through this and I know that you can
work through this 140 000 80 000 income
if you can find twenty thousand dollars
if you can find twenty five thousand
dollars a year anything is going to help
this equation move faster
right right because at this point
uprooting the family doing all this to
get a hundred thousand dollars you're
gonna have to then save up three to six
months and then you're gonna save up a
down payment and whatever you move over
to to rent is not going to be a big
difference as a matter of fact you could
end up spending more money monthly yeah
if I were in your shoes I would go
through three years of Hell rather than
sell your house
okay and the three years of Hell sounds
like this he picks up side gigs in the
ER and you find something you do to work
from home and those two things together
add forty or fifty thousand dollars to
this equation and you throw all of that
and some more uh towards the student
loan and you're done in two to three
years but you're gonna not see each
other you're gonna be tired
um you're definitely not going out to
eat you're not going on vacation you're
going to sell so much stuff around the
house that that the kids think they're
next uh I mean you're gonna your friends
are gonna be making fun of you because
you're joined a cult I mean it's you're
going to be having all of this kind of
thing going on for about two and a half
to three years and then you'll be free
forever and let me raise my hand on
something here Tristan the kids are
eight five and one and a half it may
have made more sense
several two to even two years ago to
stay at home because he had two kids
outside of kindergarten that were
younger right and now you've got a
kindergartner you've got an
eight-year-old you've only got the one
kid at home so if you found the right
gig it might do you see what I'm saying
it could be worth it to re-crunch those
numbers because that doesn't happen to
bring three kids into your home and keep
them and that's your gig
oh okay you know because people are
looking for uh inexpensive child care
now that's kind of cool too if you're I
don't know I don't know what the rules
are in Indianapolis how many kids before
you leave being a babysitter and become
a daycare but
um you don't want to get into that but
uh from a reg's regulation standpoint
and all that but anyway
you know uh people have kept other
people's children's in their home for
Generations
um and paid for it and so yeah that's
something I would consider and that's
kind of becomes a no-brainer I don't
know but and this is not you know none
of this is pleasant but selling your
home's not pleasant being in debt's not
pleasant you know nothing here there's
no Pleasant on the table for the next
two years that's true so let's just
choose our pain choose our hard and lean
into it and go at least there's an end
to the one we're describing and the end
is you know you're going to call in here
you guys are going to bring the three
kids on the show and we're going to do a
debt free Scream by God you know that's
what we're gonna do that's right we're
gonna get fired up and wired up here and
that's that's what we want for you and
we'll help you we're going to put you
into Financial Peace University our nine
week program and that'll also sign you
up for every dollar the budgeting app
and we'll show you how to do this stuff
that people are doing all the time
they've been doing it for you know 30
years I've been teaching this stuff and
be sure to to tune into our student loan
live stream that's coming up on the 12th
and I mean your big portion of this debt
is student loans and you're not alone in
that there's so many people who are
facing that and that live stream is
going to help them figure out how to
budget figure out what their payment is
figure out how to pay these things off
for good so that they're no longer
haunted by the ghost of of education's
past
and ruled by the uh well anyway we'll
just yeah we'll deal with that later
yeah so hang on uh we'll have Austin
pick up get you signed up for Financial
Peace University and get you going in
that because that's what you're gonna
have to do Tristan what we're describing
I understand it's almost bizarre it's so
weird but so is being free
being completely free of dad in America
today is so weird that it's bizarre yeah
so if you're going to have unusual
results unreasonable results you're
going to have to engage in unreasonable
behaviors and you know the lady sitting
beside me did it for seven years and Sam
yeah you work like 17 different things I
mean yeah and had little kids while
you're doing it well we the kids came
after this oh I'm sorry but I will say
you have to embrace the things that no
one else is willing to embrace you have
to do those things that people will look
at you and go wow they're weird yeah
like they're crazy they sold the
furniture in their house they're crazy
yeah that's nuts I mean they just sold
they they haven't been on vacation in
two years yeah I don't know how do you
make it yeah they they go to the
restaurant and they just order water
they're they're just there for for the
social aspect they're not there to to go
out to eat to eat they're not there for
food that's right at a restaurant yeah
that's weird that is weird I'm happy to
be weird Dave I like it going out for
drinks with my friends more water yes
I'll take the water please
water
[Laughter]
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Jade wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today I'm Dave Ramsey your host
I didn't think it was possible with the
Epic student loan debacle
for it to get any Dumber out there but
it has it's not good Dave
student loan repayment four million
people have enrolled in Biden's save
plan ahead of the payment restart
according to cnn.com yes now we know a
lot of these people were probably
automatically enrolled it says the
majority of them so basically CNN's
headline is a lie yeah four million
people enroll in Biden's save plan ahead
of payment restart no they didn't the
vast majority of them were automatically
defaulting default enrolled they didn't
voluntarily enroll they didn't actively
enroll so they didn't enroll that's
right you pushed them in like you pushed
them in that's not enrolling and so the
majority of them came out of the other
program that failed called repay and now
we're into save because we have to have
acronyms in Washington for our stupidity
right
right and what it is because what it is
is a Trap God this thing is awful it
says launched earlier this summer The
save plan save they call it saving on a
valuable education that's laughable it's
available available to most people with
federal student loans and this is what
they're saying it can provide an air
quote significant relief to borrowers
struggling to pay off their student debt
I would not be struggling to pay off
it'd be struggling to pay yeah it does
it does do that yeah okay so basically
if you sign up or accidentally were
enrolled even though you didn't enroll
in the new save plan and you're one of
those four million lost souls here's
what you're signed up for uh you have a
formula based on the poverty level that
dictates the dollar amount per month
that you are to pay
if it does not cover the interest being
charged on your student loan the
interest does not accrue
however one hundred percent so in other
words if the interest on your student
loans fifty dollars a month and the
formula says you only have to pay thirty
dollars a month you don't have any extra
interest at it on they forgive the
twenty dollars but what they fail to
mention is one hundred percent of the
thirty dollars goes to interest
consequently what is happening to your
student loan balance
here's what I want not moving it's
sitting there doofus sitting there like
a frog on a log
my God how dumb are you people in
Washington let's sign up people forgive
a portion of their interest allow them
to pay a tiny little payment with the
promise of debt forgiveness uh which you
always lie about up there I mean
perpetually lie about up there when are
you people gonna wake up oh my God it's
dumb this is ridiculous it's ridiculous
and here's my thing I'm like okay the
interest they say it's not going to
accumulate or that it will be forgiven
at the end of your term which by the way
the term starts if you let's say you
have twelve thousand dollars just twelve
thousand dollars Dave okay in student
loans okay the Forgiveness starts at 10
years of payments so they want you to
keep a twelve thousand dollar debt no
it's 20 years of payments they're
proposing to bring it back to 10. the
proposal has not gone through right now
let me say here Biden proposed
counseling up to twenty thousand dollars
unlike one-time Council yeah they're
unlike one-time cancellation professors
the same plan can benefit both current
and future borrowers which the new
people that are getting their student
loan debt can sign up for this
ridiculous less moronic thing also the
Biden Administration first said it was
developing a new repayment plan last
August save is expected to cost over no
that's not the one limit this isn't
where's this this is not the article
this is different so what it is is if
you have you you get in at twelve
thousand twelve thousand dollars equals
ten years of payments and for every
additional thousand Dave that you owe so
thirteen oh you're paying for 11 years
yeah 14 000 you're paying for 12 years
Max is after 20 years they promised to
forgive whatever's left exactly so after
you've done nothing for 20 years it's
going to be forgiven but let me help you
with the people that got promised that
ten years ago right that they were going
to have their loans forgiven for doing
for working for non-profits and in
underserved areas okay you remember
those people yeah yeah
I've applied for that
you know how many got it
1.6
so after 20 years of doing basically
nothing hoping you're going to get
forgiveness
1.6 percent of you so bad this is this
is basically the DMV of the financial
world this is the dumbest butt thing the
most inefficient socialistic garbage
I've ever seen in my life Kick the Can
down the road put your hands over yours
and go la la la la la la la la this is
not happening dumb butt idea now have I
been unclear
I hope I hadn't been unclear so how are
you going to get our student loan this
is what you need to do guys twelve
thousand dollars in debt deliver pizza
so easy like and make make two thousand
dollars a month delivering pizzas every
night and you're done in six months yeah
and you have the rest of your life
to not be screwing around with people
like the Biden Administration oh my God
yeah it's unbelievable it's unbelievable
this is
ridiculous and CNN is so stupid and you
know half the media will pick the same
this this press release by the way this
headline came from the White House yeah
it did and they republished it because
it's a lot student loan repayment four
million people in Biden's save plan had
nobody enrolled you automatically want
to defend to it yeah I mean the number
of people that physically signed up for
this idiocy on purpose is very small
but they're making it well four million
people did it you should too yeah no you
shouldn't
good Lord people when are you gonna get
a clue that the White House and the
people in Washington DC are not here to
bless you these people are what you know
what this doesn't keep you in debt your
whole freaking life
you're 35 years old you're 55 with
grandkids and you're still screwing
around with your college
you ought to have to unbelievably naive
at best stupid at worst to believe the
lies they peddle out of the Republicans
or the Democrats regarding student loans
because let me just tell you student
loans are awful they're horrible then
why do you morons keep making them now
there's the question Dave there's a
there's a dadgum
us
intellectually dishonest bunch of people
yeah you know we're going to do
everything we can to forgive your
student loans and make it easy because
there's such a burden on you while we
continue to make them to the Next
Generation you can't solve a problem a
freshman in high in college right now
we're going to put you 100 Grand in debt
unless you get a degree in left-handed
puppetry and then put you on thirty
dollars a month for the next 25 years
and then lie to you about whether we're
going to forgive it at the end of that
please people don't be so stupid this is
ridiculous it's completely out of
control this I mean I read this I got I
I you know I don't know why I got pissed
off because I should expect this kind of
stupidity out of Washington yeah and I
should expect this kind of stupidity out
of the press where they put a headline
that is completely false across the stop
top I mean this is oh geez so we're
gonna we're gonna help you with that
listen your student loan interest has
restarted it started last week okay your
payments are going to start October 1st
you know when that's going to be here
faster than Christmas it's going to be
here in a minute okay a hot minute
you're gonna have to start paying
payments again and if you're dumb enough
to sign up for a thirty dollar a month
plan and stay in debt the rest of your
life I can help you
you're just too dumb to be helped okay
that's not gonna work I can't help you
you got no more you got the motivation
of a dead brick oh come on seriously I
can help you though Jade can help you if
you will get up off your assets and go
do something about this that's right you
guys got to sign up for our student loan
it's student loans in America how we got
here how we're getting out it's a free
live stream if you have student loans
and you are not signing up for this free
live stream there's something wrong with
you and I can't help you if you want
help sign up for the live stream we're
going to tell you everything you need to
do we're going to help you hey let's
charge 30 a month for 20 years for this
oh
I mean that would make it popular and
four million people could accidentally
sign up for it
isn't that funny Dave how when we want
to do something to set people free that
sounds asinine yeah well it sounds like
you you're you people are taking
advantage of poor people by giving you a
free live stream would you shut up
seriously it's free
figure out how that's manipulative okay
that's free yeah Jade is going to show
you we're gonna I know some of you are
scared okay well then do something about
it I know some of you are confused good
do something about it I'll show you how
I've been doing this for 30 years and it
ain't gonna be you screw around with
this for the rest of your life I can
promise you this spoiler alert you're
gonna get with it you're gonna get a
callus on your working hand baby this is
what you're gonna do you're gonna go and
don't worry about working too hard just
before you die you'll pass out it's okay
we're going to teach you how to do this
stuff sign up student loan live stream
ramseysolutions.com student loans
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their why
guarantee and erson is always free see
whyblinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings go
to blinds.com now and save 50 off
selected products visit blinds.com today
for more info
[Music]
thank you
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America Jake is with us in Dayton Ohio
hi Jake how are you
hey thanks for taking Michael good how
can we help
um so World got a little flipped upside
down
um
I got a injury
I'm 26 and they said that I'm gonna need
a total knee replacement and
it's not going to affect my career now
however in the next 10 to 15 years I'll
need a second knee replacement
and based off of that they said a decent
chance that I would not be able to go
back to work
that without that job
yeah in this career field so I'm uh I'm
in law enforcement so okay my thought
process I'm trying to figure out is
do I go ahead and switch careers now
because I I don't want to you know keep
dumping money into a pension and then be
40 with kids and then have to switch
careers and take a takea because
everything I'm looking at right now is a
significant pay cut to where I'm at
okay well let's just change the set of
assumptions
uh what do you make
um last year with overtime I made 102.
okay all right
so
the assumption that you can't make 102
ever again in your life is not a correct
assumption
no sir yeah I get that it's just
everything I'm looking at right now I
know but yeah but right now your heart's
kind of broken because you've been had
your height your your sights set on
being in law enforcement your whole life
or a large portion of your life and
you're heavily invested and then you got
injured and you've gone through the
trauma the emotional trauma of the
injury and the physical trauma and now
they're telling you that that you know
your dream's gonna die early
right and so in that mindset you usually
don't see this the sunlight you usually
see the storm clouds
that would be in human nature not not
that you're a bad guy okay but I'm not
sitting in all that mess that you've
been through and so for me I'm got a 26
year old guy who's bright enough to
become a police officer he's bright
enough to become a lot of things
between now and 10 years from now
I mean you could open a business and
make 2 million a year I don't know
how old are you uh 26. I'm 26. and I
since I found this out uh I signed up
for classes again and me and my wife are
cash flowing that good but I'm just
trying to yeah I just don't know like
how long is too long to stay in this
career based off of you know like when
when's the best time to switch careers
well number one you don't want to get
injured again
um or or you know leave your partner in
trouble because of an injury or
something like that
um and number two you don't want to uh
you know wear it all the way down but do
we have to decide this week no we don't
start this week I mean we have to go
work at Chick-fil-A no crap no that's
not what you're doing okay you but you
know what I would do is say okay over
the next two to three years I'm gonna
develop occur my next my Encore career
my next career after the curtain goes
down and comes back up and I'm Gonna Get
You know what classes I have to take or
certifications I have to take to be that
and I'm going to become a student of Ken
Coleman and and go live my next dream
which
oddly enough might end up better
now I like that that's interesting yeah
yeah that's thinking God's making me
making me change a career here so I'm
just trying to figure out well what what
what kind of timeline is here you know
yeah maybe or or you know
um you know my whole life was set up for
me to be a real estate investor
and then my real estate portfolio is
deeply in debt and I lost everything and
I was 28 years old just a tiny bit older
than you with a brand new baby and a
toddler and um and went bankrupt and
lost everything and so um I get to have
a new career after that because guess
what they don't loan you a bunch of
money at the bank to go do flips if you
just file bankruptcy so that was kind of
out and so those days were over plus I
was done with them because it didn't
bring me a lot of fun and so and about
the time your knee got busted you know
you're you're part you're partially over
being a policeman at that point because
you're like this this is less fun than I
thought it was going to be yeah you know
and so you're having a little bit of
that same kind of an experience and you
get this next chapter of your life this
uh second half so to speak and I yeah
you know I think about things like that
even what you just said Dave I was just
about to say I came from entertainment I
was an Entertainer my entire life and
then covet happened and there was no
entertainment and I had to contemplate
my life and I realized being
entertaining that's how low we got but I
realized hey there's other things I can
do there's other things I'm good at and
I think that you'll find the same thing
and I'm the type of person where I think
we just go from from good to better to
best like if you if you're living your
life right it's just getting better and
better and I think that this has the
opportunity to take you on yet another
adventure that's going to have another
great outcome you know being a law
enforcement officer is going to be the
first part and then you're going to move
on to something else and then who knows
you might move on to something else but
that's just the evolution of life and
it's not a failure it's not an it
doesn't have to be a negative this can
be a this can be one of the greatest
things that's ever happened to you
because it'll open that that next door
you don't know what's going to be behind
it but you got to keep turning those
knobs and something's going to be behind
there and you're going to look back on
this and go man here's what my prayer
always is
I want to look back and go man I'm so
grateful XYZ happened because when that
happened it allowed me to do this this
and that and this has the potential to
do that for you you'll look at this
right now it's painful it sucks but in a
couple of years and eight years in 12
years
yes you know I never would have been at
Ramsay if it wasn't for 2020 yeah yeah
and everybody hated 2020. thank you
thank you found she that's the only time
we'll say it that's the only time the
only time you ever hear that
nobody nobody except the Plexiglas
people say thank you falci I'm just
saying now that's what it means to get
fouchied then uh
so yeah that's the thing anyway but I
mean yeah the point is I mean I I didn't
I didn't sign up for bankruptcy it
wasn't what I wanted no uh and I I won't
say it's the worst it's the worst thing
that ever happened to me and it's the
best thing I've ever attacked I agree
both yeah very dramatic dramatic uh and
I I you know I I still you know we've
got the actual bankruptcy filing on the
wall wow bankruptcy out here in the in
the Ramsey Lobby when you come out here
just so you can see how this started and
I walked by that I still kind of go yeah
you know I was like oh crud you know but
and it's been 30 years and I still get
the heebie-jeebies but yeah but so it's
not like I'm still joyful about the
whole thing but you know I never would
have sold 10 million books Selling
Houses yeah I feel I I thank God that we
went through that 460 000 of debt
checked at the time I'm gonna sign you
up for Ken Coleman's uh career
assessment and it takes about 15 minutes
to take I'm gonna give it to you free
and I want you to take that and it's
going to kind of point you in some
directions that you probably were
already thinking about but it'll start
to give you some clarity on that and I'm
also going to send you his book from
paycheck to purpose because I think what
you've got here is not the end of the
play I think you've got the second act
or between the First Act and the second
act and um there's no rush you said
you've got 10 years before this is going
to go sideways on you so to speak and
um but so I mean we can take two or we
can take six months and figure this out
we do want to actively figure it out
though we don't want to sit and let this
situation happen to you that's right you
want to happen to it be proactive but
let's determine you know okay here's the
direction and then and let me tell you
what the direction is Jake the direction
is not go back to school
that's a good point that isn't people
get this I just go back to school for
what because if you don't know because
that's just I just go back to school no
that's Dumber in a rock you may be
studying exactly the wrong thing and you
may not even need to go to school for
what you're thinking about doing so um
when we talked to a guy the other day
he's making 300 000 a year and he has a
landscaping business he cuts grass yeah
you know yes shut up yeah do not go back
to school unless you know you've done
your research and you're locked in you
have to have it yeah you definitely
don't go into debt for it no but you
have to have them you have to have the
degree or the knowledge base to open up
the fee you know it's permission to play
in the field you're going into right
okay and so you know what we got to do
there uh and you know it could be as
simple as I may not be appealing to you
could be as simple as you work on your
Master's level stuff and uh admit in Law
Enforcement Administration and you move
up into leadership and you know where
the knee is not the problem and that
changes the whole discussion I don't
know and maybe maybe you're but maybe
your law of a law enforcement parlays
you up into that it's okay to be either
any of those but do it intentionally
take two to three years to get tooled up
begin to make your move gradually so you
sneak up on this it doesn't sneak up on
you and we'll send you the tools from
Ken Coleman to help you do that this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
home buying Market but there's a way you
can get an edge Churchill Mortgage works
with you to understand your budget and
your goals and the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge offers you fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus Churchill has bumped up their
seller guarantee to ten thousand dollars
giving your offer the best chance of
being accepted and helping you win in
today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today Jim is
with us in Nashville hey Jim welcome to
the Ramsay show how can we help
hey Dave glad to talk to you you too man
enjoy your show thank you all right
um I am calling in response to a video I
saw recently that you claimed infinite
banking concept was a scam and actually
got quite pissed off about it so um I um
do not agree with that in certain points
that you made in that um video and I
have set up a policy for my son uh when
he was one years old he's five now I'm
sure
um
say that again I said I'm sorry
books
yeah so am I sometimes no
uh so uh so I set that policy up for
when we was one years old
um it has a 500 000 face value we pay
five thousand three hundred seventy
three dollars a year for 13 years and
it's paid up at that point
um there's a few points that I wanted to
discuss that I just didn't agree with
um do you want to just kind of take one
thing at a time that's fine sure okay
um one of the main things was that you
claim that the cash value dies with you
and you only get um to face value uh
paid out that's true that is well it's
not true if you reinvest the dividends
back into policy dividend reinvestment
is not cash value
dividend reinvestment is because you
have a mutual company and the
policyholders are the owners of the
company and so the profits from the
company come to the policyholder and
they use that to buy paid up additions
that is not the same as keeping your
cash value that's buying extra insurance
with your overpayment
but it still works out to be no
um having a cash value much greater than
the 69
849 we put into it but the actual cash
value not the paid up additions the
actual cash value dies with you
no because yeah okay but but your your
death benefit is larger than your cash
value so it so whoever you're so for me
I looked at it because you bought
General Insurance
you don't want a paid up addition as a
paid up addition is buying additional
insurance
and that's why they're getting more at
death not because you got your cash
value but because you used your policy
dividends to buy additional insurance
right but that's different than getting
your cash value if you if you took those
policy dividends and went and bought a
term insurance policy for a hundred
thousand well you'd get a hundred
thousand but that's not your cash value
well I have a Term Policy now but you
missed my point okay let you're talking
about you use the policy dividends you
use the money they send to you because
you're in a mutual company to buy
additional Insurance yes pay the
petitions yeah yeah if you buy a term
policy on the side for a hundred
thousand dollars instead with that same
money you would get a hundred thousand
dollars more than your face value but
that's not your cash value that's
additional Insurance they're different
but in right they are different in term
you can't you don't have cash value to
borrow again I'm aware of that but your
point was that you don't lose the cash
value and my point is 100 of the time by
definition you lose the cash value okay
but okay so as I said Tit for Tat if he
lives to be 80 I'm looking at the uh the
um
read out here if you say he only lives
to be 80. okay all right the cash value
will be worth about two million dollars
but the payout for the death benefit
will be 2.6 million so okay technically
so you take the cash you take you're
taking your bent your policy dividends
and go buy term insurance with it and
you would have more than you're talking
about because you get a better buy on
the insurance than you're getting with
this ripoff whole life crap yes you
would get a high but you wouldn't be
able to use it throughout your life as a
as your own bank I think that's okay but
here's the thing the big thing that's a
side issue that's a side issue but your
first issue was you know he's going to
have all this money at retirement well
let's just do a little present value
calculation on what you put in for a
baby five thousand dollars a year for 13
years do you know what that would be in
a mutual fund
instead of putting it into this rip-off
thing and making four percent on your
money and when he dies he loses his cash
value if you put this in a good mutual
fund you'd have a hundred X 10x the
amount of money and that's your infinite
freaking bank but I we're only putting
in seventy thousand and he's going to be
that's how present value formula Works
in finance you know
[Music]
let's intellectually deal with this for
a second okay take the same amount of
money when you get off the air and put
it in a financial calculator at 11
percent
and pretend it was invested in mutual
funds and see what it is when he's 88
years old it'll be more a whole lot more
but and he'll have that too with this to
me is a way to no he doesn't have to to
borrow against that's what you that's
called opportunity cost on your money
you put it into something that's going
to make him at 88 have two and a half
million and he should have had 25
million because you screwed up and put
it in the wrong thing well we when we
screwed up and put it in real estate too
and he's going to get real estate but
then put the money in real estate but
don't put it in this crap
to respectfully disagree well on what
basis he's getting more money if you put
it somewhere else
but he's able to borrow against this
if you've got 25 million in mutual funds
you can borrow against it but he's he's
gonna have to wait until he's you know
to get that amount of money okay so
you're going to teach him that the way
he becomes wealthy is borrowing against
money that his father invested for him
that's how he builds wealth
said no one rich ever
I mean Banks use this product to no they
do not you've been watching too much
Tick Tock Banks do not use whole life
not ever
thanks nowhere
I would especially disagree no they
don't they do not use whole life life
insurance what bank well
I mean we we Google it and see what
typically Banks do with their money but
um I I believe typically Banks never put
money let me tell you what banks do they
put it in bonds they're required to they
wouldn't be allowed by federal
regulations
hmm it's not a place to invest money
because it's a horrible investment the
rate of return sucks and when you die
you lose your cash value I know but says
but you also
you don't you're making it sound like
I'm losing money on the whole you are
you're leaving money on the table you're
making it sound like when not me but my
son when he dies yeah that he's only
going to be able to get his he's going
to have 22 million dollars less than he
should have if you would put this in a
good investment
you had mentioned that the cash value
guys and you only get the face value
that's not true that is true that's not
I just I just covered that with you for
the last 10 minutes paid up additions
are the only way that cash value
increases unless you're using a
Universal Life program B where you pay
extra to get the extra insurance which
is another form of paid up additions
that hasn't come out of my pocket though
I put 70 that is coming out of your
pocket it's coming out of the policies
pocket I know the policy you put the
money in dude and then it paid you a
dividend and you chose to buy more of
this crap with the dividend and you're
calling that I kept my cash value no you
didn't you bought more insurance
well I know that I put in 70 000 and at
a certain age it's going to be at age
when he's 15 years old that's going to
be paid up yeah Jim and you understand
what paid up is you understand if you're
alive that there's a probability of your
death and so 100 of the time that a life
insurance program is paid up it means
that you prepaid it that's all it means
because as long as there's a probability
of death there's a cost so the insurance
companies always got a cost as long as
you're alive so there is no such thing
as a paid up that's a that's an industry
term that gets suckers like you that's
what it is now paid up means prepaid you
paid all of the premiums in 13 years for
his whole freaking life in advance
that's why it's paid up that hey man I
think you ought to keep it it's perfect
for you but thanks for the call
[Music]
thank you
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramsesolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade wash all Ramsay
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money open funds at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five KC starts off this hour in
Charlotte North Carolina hi Casey how
are you
what are you guys doing better than I
deserve what's up
so I'm a uh Army recruiter and I recruit
for active duty in the reserve thank you
and uh thank you I appreciate it but um
when I talk to kids about active duty
it's easy when we're talking about
college because the arm will just pay
100 tuition and give them a paycheck
absolutely
but when I talk about the reserve it
gets a bit more complicated and part of
the incentive for the reserve is that we
have a student loan repayment up to like
fifty thousand dollars and I don't know
what advice to give to these young men
and women when I'm sitting down with
them so right now I'm telling them hey
take out the student loan and the Army
will pay it back for you but put it in a
CD and keep it safe and then use it as
like uh I'm getting out of the army
bonus after it's been paid off but I
don't know if that's good advice because
I don't like to give advice yeah that
says hey take on debt I don't know what
else to tell them because it's free
money for them I appreciate that
um the um well that'll work only if it
works and you know you're asking an 18
year old to be smart
um and you're you're in the Army you
know better
right and a lot of times it's a I sit
down with the parents and yeah I know
and I tell them I know you know what I'm
you know what I'm saying and so uh yeah
now the uh we do some work with the Air
National Guard and the Army National
Guard both and they have a ten thousand
dollar uh tuition program does the
reserves not have that too
so we do
um we if we actually have this uh four
thousand dollars a year of tuition
assistance and we also have a monthly
stipend that goes up to a thousand
dollars a month as well and that's has
nothing else added to or like about a
thousand dollars a month and that
stipend's just a reserve stipend that's
not for Education only right
no that's that's for Education only oh
really and they also have their regular
paycheck as well okay so they got the
regular paycheck and they get a thousand
dollars a month if they want to go to
school stipend and four thousand dollar
reimbursement
it's a four thousand dollar tuition
assistance they pay the school directly
up to four thousand dollars a year per
year for per year and the twelve
thousand dollars goes how long
how long can you get the thousand
dollars how many years
as long as you're getting your your
first degree
okay so you could do four years which
would be forty eight thousand and you
could do four times so sixteen thousand
yeah
well it'll be um yeah they only get the
paycheck while they're in school the
extra thousand a month while they're in
school so in the summertime they don't
get that pay
okay oh so it's not a full 12 000 a year
all right so it would be nine thousand
dollars a year so yeah yeah so we call
that thirty eight thousand right or
thirty seven thousand and thirty six
thousand I'm sorry and the um
and then we get 16 000 on top of that
which is the four years of four thousand
correct that's more than fifty thousand
dude
right I'm just and they don't have to
take out the loan
okay I just like to give them as much
money as I can I appreciate that I I
would not ask them to step up on the uh
so here's here's here's my principle
number one I don't borrow money you know
that principle you knew that for your
call and again thank you for your uh
service and for what you do okay but
want the principal the other principle
is violating for me uh is
um
the uh uh okay almost every time that
you borrow money it only works if it
works
and life doesn't always work and so
you've got this plan I'm going to open a
business and I'm gonna borrow ten
thousand dollars and I'm gonna make a
hundred thousand dollars until you fall
off the tractor break your hip and you
lose everything and now you've just got
the debt and you don't have the business
okay or until you you know it works if I
buy a car on payments until I lose my
job and I can't pay the payments and it
gets repo it works if I they do this
until until until it only works if it
works and in our minds when we analyze
using debt it we only analyze the if it
works part not if it doesn't work part
the risk part and uh the second thing
that I another principle we use around
here is uh I like to put my life on wise
autopilot and avoid stupid autopilot
autopilot mean that it automatically is
going to be smart even if I leave it
alone
and I don't have to assume that an 18
year old suddenly is going to be with
the help of his parents or without wise
and keep in control until he's 25 and
not screw this up
I mean you're just asking for trouble
here
you've been I mean you recruit these
guys every day
I know I just trying to give them the
best advice I can I know but I'm just
not even going to tell you if they get
if they take the money out or not
because I'm not going to ask kind of
with or without me you know I've done
youth ministry and I'm not going to ask
those people at that age with that level
of brain development
to take on the level of discipline and
leave their hands off of this and not go
to Hawaii with their girlfriend
we're using this money I'm just not
going to ask them to do that because
it's going to get screwed up it'll never
happen you know it's going to get
screwed up so I would I would man I
think you guys got a great program with
the stipend I knew there was about 10
grand like like there was like the like
the National Guard has but I didn't know
exactly what so 12 000 No 9 000 after
you take the summer off but if you if
you go to school all summer do you get
the stipend still
yeah yeah as long as you're in school
you get the stipend okay so if you just
went to school if you went to school 12
months a year if you went to school 12
months a year for four years you'd get
48 000 bucks plus the 4K yeah maximum is
36 months oh okay
it does max out in four years on nine
months then okay
so you might as well not okay so we'll
do the four years of nine months get the
36 000 I'll get the 16 000 reimbursement
as well and
um and so that puts me at what 52 000
bucks right
user yeah and that's a great benefit a
kid that doesn't is trying to figure out
a way to go to college you can go to
college by joining the resort they still
get FAFSA and they can still get all the
other scholarships yeah we just we just
gave you a great commercial
I appreciate that but I do I believe in
it I mean we endorse the National Guard
and the Air National Guard both they're
some of our sponsors on different things
because of this subject this is the
reason they come to us and the reason we
like to endorse them is because we
freaking hate student loans and you do
too Casey you're a good man thank you so
he's got a great heart he wants you to
make sure these kids get all they can
get yeah I mean but I I
I wouldn't I wouldn't go with the risk
on the on the loan no you can't you
can't trust 18 year olds to
I wouldn't trust me at 18 and I was a
little nerd me too I was a goody two
shoes and I would have I wasn't good at
two shoes but I was a math nerd and I
was I was always trying to scheme or
scam figure out a way to make it work I
would have been the guy that did that
yeah and then I would have been the guy
went to Hawaii too I was gonna say I
would have had a new purse in Hawaii
yeah that's it well I wouldn't have had
a purse but there's that
thank God yeah that was long that was
long ago there were no Mercies in those
days
oh my goodness gracious help us Jesus
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsay we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today Landon
is in South Bend Indiana hey Landon
welcome to the Ramsey Show
right how can we help
hey
um so I'm a new home buyer or a
homeowner and
I just uh I did get it financed and I'm
basically in a situation where the money
that I make I am spending on my bills
and paying for mortgage and I am just
curious
um what is the best way to get to
Financial Freedom from where I'm at
it sounds like you maybe bought too much
house and you don't have margin is that
what I'm hearing
well
um basically long story short uh I was
renting from my employer
um which is also my brother-in-law and
I'm sorry that sounds like a horrible
situation but keep going well it's not a
horrible situation but
um basically they offered to finance a
house for me because I wanted to put
that money towards a house versus just
renting
and so they
um I didn't have anything to put down so
they financed it 100
um and it's at seven percent
um interest
um I was able
the payment's Eleven Hundred and how
much do you make every month
uh right now my bring home is 36. yeah
yeah you're gonna feel that
so yeah
here's what we need to do if we need if
we're going to make this work long term
because it's in the house is still in
your name right they just gave you the
money for the down payment right
correct okay if you're gonna make this
work long haul we need to get this to
where it's no more than 25 percent right
just so you can breathe do you have any
other debt
um I have about three thousand dollars I
owe on my truck and that is through them
as well if that is interest-free
why do you keep borrowing money through
your workplace
um like I said it's family and they were
just trying to help me
um get basically a leg up and get
um
get started I was in a bad situation how
old are you Linda
22. what do you do for a living
[Music]
maintenance manager at their
out there okay
[Music]
um they are trying to do a nice thing
for you but they have done it in such a
way that it is a curse and not a
blessing
[Music]
because you called because you can't
breathe
right
and you owe all this money to your
brother-in-law who also is your employer
and so if you screw up uh making a
payment it affects your job if you screw
up your job it affects whether you keep
your truck
you're walking around carrying three or
four hundred pounds on your back all day
long trying to breathe I'm so sorry and
again I don't think they did this to
harm you they were trying to be helpful
but but sir you have you have a curse on
you yeah and so um and the reason let's
just get this going moving forward the
reason that you had to borrow money for
a truck is because you couldn't afford a
truck and the reason that you had to
borrow the money to buy a house is
because you couldn't afford to buy a
house you bought a house that you really
can't afford
um and uh you're 22 years old
man I'm just my heart's hurting for you
right now because I mean you got a lot
of pressure on you man
and so um now the house was theirs and
they sold it to you right
no it was
um actually a private sale oh you went
they went and bought a house or you and
they went they gave you the cash to go
buy a house and they financed the whole
thing
yeah
oh okay so what do you owe on this house
well I owe right around I think it's 58
158 000. okay all right do you have any
I when did you buy it
uh I bought it and
um
I guess I would have bought it in May
what do you think it's worth
Praises for
uh it appraisals for 180.
sell it
okay
dude you can't breathe
let me ask a question
I have a question about this if you turn
around and sell this house are you
worried about what they're gonna think
that you just used them to get this
house so that you could turn a profit
not not really just that I mean I'm not
I would be lying if I said that wasn't
on my mind
um I would go in and sit down with your
brother-in-law and say I made a mistake
I can't pay this payment and the truck
payment on my income I can't breathe the
stress is killing me I'm gonna sell the
house and I don't want you to think I'm
doing it because yes and I don't want
you to think I'm ungrateful I am not
ungrateful and I didn't trick you I
can't breathe and I'm putting the house
on the market that's what I was with the
conversation I don't think you're gonna
do that because I don't think you're in
as much pain as I think you should be
well if he can if he can find a thousand
extra dollars a month if he can find a
way to permanently get his income up get
rid of this truck payment he might be
able to he would be able to continue on
considering that's his only debt we
didn't get further far enough into it
let me just tell you
it's a bad idea to owe your house
payment to your employer who's also your
brother it's a bad idea to owe your
house payment to your brother-in-law it
is a triple X bad idea to owe it to your
brother-in-law who is your employer man
there's so many things that can go wrong
with this that have lifetime
implications Thanksgiving dinner not a
blessing and again I don't think he's a
the mother-in-law's a bad guy I think
he's just dumb
and he was trying to do a nice thing in
a and he did it in a dumb way without
thinking about he made the assumption
that this young man needs to own a house
and he's wasting money when he's renting
and we're going to get him a house and
we did him a favor and that's what's
going through this guy's mind but he's
wrong he made a mistake I mean it's the
equivalent all of that co-signing I'm
gonna buy my kids a house all these
things I'm going to buy land and then
the kids can live on the house all those
ideas where you're you're um you're
trying to manipulate someone else's
financial situation they can't afford it
that's why they don't have it and if you
don't the reason your grandson needs a
co-signer for the Raptor is because he's
too broke to buy a wrap he can't afford
it hello yeah this is not hard and
Landon that's you you're too broke to
bought this house you shouldn't have
bought it and you bought a house you
can't afford it's not a super expensive
house and it sounds like the good news
is you can get out of it and with your
skin intact
um I don't think you're going to sell it
though I'm talking to you yeah he's 22
he doesn't need to have a brand new
house and a brand new truck or or a used
house in a used truck yeah and it's okay
it's um I I would get the truck pay I
sell the house I'd pay off the truck and
I'd start piling up money and I start
working on my career goals and what am I
going to be when I'm 32. yeah and what
am I going to be doing that I make 60 80
100 000 when I'm 32 and and because you
don't want to be doing exactly the same
thing no matter what you're doing when
you're 22 when you're 32. so the way he
has that conversation though is key down
you got to go in there just play the
cards say what happened but if you got
to believe that too I'm not sure he
believes that
no I yeah I don't know that he believes
it's the right answer but he did say it
was bothering him look if I I if I was a
certain type of person and I said hey
I'm going to help you get in this house
I would never do that but I could see
how they might go oh
you just wanted us to flip this out for
you yeah yeah and I think it's okay to
say out loud this is yeah I'm scared to
death and
um and does and they don't get to talk
you out of it you're still going to sell
it right but you just let them know two
problems or you know one is a all right
two things I didn't buy it to flip and
and two is I'm not ungrateful but the
reason I'm selling it is I'm so scared I
can't I'm scared specialist and this is
killing me I'm carrying 300 pounds
around on my back yeah that's connected
to my job and my family yeah exactly
exactly which is like a triple X reason
not to do that oh my gosh extra large
extra extra extra large problem a triple
X problem Rick's in the backpack extra
large extra extra large this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
over your head with student loans and
tired of getting calls from collection
agencies if private student loan debt is
taking away your financial piece and you
don't see any way out you need why refi
they're not a debt settlement company
and they're not connected to a bank why
refi refinances defaulted private
student loans that other places won't
touch and gives you a custom loan built
for you based on your ability to pay so
when you refinance your private student
loan debt with why refi you'll have a
payment you can afford with a low fixed
interest rate you couldn't get anywhere
else to help you stick to your budget
and work the debt snowball and you can
save thousands of dollars to learn more
about this custom refinancing option and
a lump sum payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you for joining us America Jade
wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
she and Rachel Cruz and I will be
co-hosting each other or whatever you
call it all together on a live stream
this coming Tuesday
and that is September the 12th at 7 pm
central time it is completely free it is
student loan debt in America how we got
here and how to get out there is a lot
of extremely bogus programs coming out
of Washington right now that are really
misleading and scary and
um we we want to not just beat up on
Washington although that's a lot of fun
but aside from that we we what we really
want to do is just show you guys some
hope some actual facts of people that
got out Jade got out of 260 280
000. I keep trying to call it 360. don't
don't short change that 20. all right
280 000 she and Sam worked their tail
ends off 465 000 total in debt that they
cleared up it took them a long time it
took them seven years yeah it's not
going to take you guys that long because
most of you a don't have 465 475 000 in
debt B
um you you know you probably are in a
different place than they were when they
started this so there's a whole story
there she's going to tell you that story
but we're also going to show you story
after story after Story of people who
did just like you
single moms people who
lost their job people who couldn't get a
job in their career field and they still
figured out a way to do this and we'll
help you we're going to show you how I
know it's confusing I know it's scary
and so sign up go to ramseysolutions.com
student loans sign up for the free live
stream it is this coming Tuesday night
do not miss it it's free what do you got
to lose
your student loans oh that was an
underhand pitch it was Tiffany is with
us from Chicago hi Tiffany how are you
I'm good how are you better than we
deserve how can we help
I have a question about my car I am
upside down in my car loan but it is my
only primary uh source of transportation
and I have two children that I have to
take care of so I don't know what to do
you single
I am okay
how much is the car worth
um the car is worth five thousand
dollars give or take a couple hundred
um and the car loan is 20 grand
what how in the world wow how'd you get
so far upside down
um well when I bought the car it uh was
added like one of those like Buy Here
Pay Here shops and I really just needed
a car because I had to get back and
forth to work and take care of the kids
so you got screwed pretty much pretty
much I now know that now like a year
after I paid for it or I'm paying for it
so you overpaid for it did you trade a
car that had negative equity into it no
um
wow you just really overpaid you you
overpaid you overpaid ten thousand
dollars
yes really
yes I did I I really was on um I did I
wasn't I wasn't knowledgeable enough to
know what I was getting myself into and
I like I said I just really did okay let
me let me stop your second so is the
note still at The Tote The Note lot
yes okay the payment that the payoff
they're giving you is not the payoff
okay that's what's called there's two
ways to calculate a rip-off car loan
okay and this is a rip-off car loan no
doubt about it okay subprime lending
what what one way they calculated they
you ask them what what's your loan
balance and the way they keep the loan
balance on the books is called top total
of payments which is a total of all your
payments over the whole time including
the ridiculous Bud interest rate that
they're charging that is twenty thousand
okay you do not owe twenty thousand
dollars on the car though that's just if
you pay every payment and add them all
together
interesting okay that's a top
calculation and that's the account
balance that is different than the
payoff balance in a sub now in a regular
car loan that they're the same thing the
payoff and the account are the same
thing they just keep your account
balance your principal balance is all
they give you but on a rip-off loan on a
subprime loan they'll put it on the
balance on the books as a top and what
that does is it it takes all your hope
away and you feel stuck which is why you
called so the good news is is the payoff
on that car is what's the interest rate
17 15.
um I think it's like 23. yeah okay good
good yeah okay so the great that's even
better news because that means that the
20 includes all that
okay so that tells me the payoff on this
car is probably closer to 10.
really yeah yeah so if you just call
them and say I want to know so how bad
your credit
uh it's pretty bad pretty bad it's like
horrible High fours um
couldn't be any worse okay yeah and so
uh your single mom what do you make
um I bring home probably like 3 100 a
month
what do you do
um I'm a retail supervisor how old your
babies
um my son is going to be 12 tomorrow and
uh my baby is nine months
who watches the baby during the day
um they go between my mother and uh
their father okay good so do you have
any other debt besides this car
yes can you look can you go through that
um I have proc probably maybe
about six thousand dollars in credit
card loan or credit cards I have um
about 73 000 in student loans and I
probably have about five thousand
dollars and um
uh regular loans and then I probably
have I think another 13 000 in a car
that I totaled
oh no insurance yeah no insurance hey
what's your degree in
um I didn't even graduate okay I just
kind of floated through school and then
how old are you ended up having a baby I
am 33. okay
all right girlfriend
we do have a mess and
um everything you told me it told us in
that list adds up to chaos
absolutely there's a lot of Chaos in
your life and there has been for an
extended period of time
in order to clean up the finances we
also have to clean up the chaos
because the chaos is causing you to feel
desperate and stuck and right after I
get desperate I get stupid
and so have you a time or two
yes you feel stuck and desperate and you
go to a car and Tote The Note lot and
get ripped off because you didn't feel
like there's anything else you could do
because you're desperate
right yeah okay all right so we got to
calm down back up and say all right
couple things we're number one
uh Tiffany one of the things I
discovered because I grew up without any
money did you grow up without money
yes yeah and I found out that rich
people think different
they think
every time they make a decision how does
this affect me 10 years from today
when I grew up we thought about how
Friday was going to be
exactly Thank God It's Friday oh God
it's Monday
right and we turned up the music about
four o'clock Friday afternoon and tried
to forget that Monday was coming
and that makes you broke when your
planning window is short you make Dumber
decisions than if you have a long-term
planning window rich people think when
they buy a car how's this going to play
out in 10 years you thought I got to get
to work tomorrow
exactly and so what I want you to do
slow down is with every decision you
make from the day forward about money
and about your career I want you to
think about 42 year old Tiffany and how
she's going to like this version of
Tiffany that's 32. okay
so we're going to think like rich people
we're going to think long term and then
it that'll draw you up out of the mud of
the chaos slowly
this is going to be slowly does that
make sense absolutely okay so let's do
two steps
that I can think of and then you jump in
okay I gotta get these out of my system
before number one uh I wanna do I'm out
of time
go ahead hang on hang on through the
break hang on through the break can you
because you you need some help girl we
can't just dump you into a commercial
break so you hang on we're gonna come
back and give you some actual uh
marching orders okay
okay thank you we'll be right back this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you three months free to
get started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow is
Catholic you can tailor the content
towards your faith tradition if you
don't have a faith tradition this is a
great place to learn more about it from
scripture readings and prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and to
remember hallow is giving you 90 days
free imagine the peaceful habits you can
establish in 90 days go to hallow.com
Ramsay today and follow the simple
prompts to start your free 90-day trial
that's hallow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
personality is my co-host today we're
talking with Tiffany in Chicago she has
a nine month old 12 month old she's
making Thirty One hundred dollars a
month she she has a car that is valued
at about five thousand we think the
payoff is around ten thousand with a
Tote The Note lot she's got a lot of
other miscellaneous debts and uh has had
and we established early a lot of chaos
and disorganization in her process and
we're discussing what her next steps are
so Jade I'll let you jump in yeah I
think right now obviously we've got a
bit of an income problem and I want to
try to find where where we can find some
of this money so my first question to
you Tiffany is what's your living
situation are you living with anybody is
anyone living with you tell me about
that
oh well let me try that picking up the
line that'll help okay now go ahead
Tiffany
oh I'm sorry it was our fault I didn't
pick up the line uh can you hear me yes
ma'am we can now oh yeah I was
like what happened
um it's just me and my kids and I rent
um and my rent's probably like twelve
hundred dollars so good um
so 1200 rent
um I want to know are you getting a tax
return every year
um
a little bit I I've adjusted that uh to
not get one because I have been uh
trying to get out of this mess since
I've known it that it was a mess and I
kind of figured listened a lot to Dave
Ramsey and I bought the total Total
Money Makeover and I was like oh my gosh
this is such a light to my eyes and I
feel so much less stressed so I have
adjusted that uh to make sure I do get
if I do get anything it's very minimal
so I can make sure I can pay my bills
and how many hours a week are you
working
I work um 80 and if they offer over time
I am the first one to volunteer
but at 40 and I know you've got the kids
it sounds like you've got some family in
the area that'll help you you got it at
this point it's an equation right we got
it we gotta make a bigger shovel because
you have a big hole right to fill up
um and that's gonna look like you
looking for employment that at the core
earns more right so I want you to I want
you to start you know
beefing up the resume I want you to
start looking for jobs that you can
transfer your skill set and so before we
get off the line we're going to get you
hooked up with Ken Coleman stuff I'm
sure you've seen it but we'll make sure
you have that because I want your core
income to be bigger uh when Sam and I
were paying off our debt when we started
we were making thirty thousand that is
unsustainable it we could do all the
side hustles in the world and it
wouldn't have made a difference so you
got to get the core income up and then
in the meantime while you're working
towards that you do need side hustles
also Yeah so basically those two things
together will double your income on the
short term on the short term okay and
you can do that and then when you start
cleaning this up now you said you had a
repo debt of how much
um 13 000. okay and what was the other
debts other than the five thousand on
her the ten thousand on the car
s
um
another six
this is off the top of my head I'm sorry
um probably like another ticks in loans
um 73 in student loans
um I think that's it okay about it about
a hundred thousand so you're not paying
on the student loans yet you're not
paying on the 13 000 repo at this point
are you no good okay so you've only got
the credit cards and the other loan that
you're paying a little bit on we're
gonna cut up the credit cards you've
already probably done that after reading
total money so here's the thing I one of
the things I discovered I told you I
didn't grow up with money one of the
things I discovered was I could learn
from anybody about anything by reading
you read The Total Money Makeover and it
helped you agreed
so if I stack books on you right now
will you read them because I'm gonna
give you a bunch of them if you'll do it
absolutely all right all right so we're
going to send you Ken Coleman's book
from paycheck to purpose we're also
going to set you up with his assessment
to because I want you to aim at a
long-term career right now we're going
to get the core income up and the shadow
so like Jade said but I want you to
think about who Tiffany's going to be
when she is 30 and when she's 42 and
what are you going to be doing you're
going to be an executive sitting in an
office corner office somewhere smiling
making 100 Grand doing what I don't care
you go get go to code school I don't
care what you're going to do all right
but you figure that out all right then
the second thing I want you to do is I
want you to go to let me see here I'm
gonna get this up uh go to this go go to
uh listen to this podcast Craig
groeschel and the nut last name is
g-r-o-e-s-c-h-e-l he's a pastor he is a
leadership podcast the guest on the
podcast like three or four episodes back
was an African-American lady came from
where you are she's now the president of
the Dallas Mavs
oh my gosh and she was the CEO of at T
at one point she's a force to be
reckoned with I thoroughly enjoyed
listening to the podcast she was
inspiring to me and she will be to you
because I want her future I want her
situation to be your future okay okay I
want you thinking like that because I I
want you to break this cycle for your
nine month old and for your 12 year old
it stops with you okay okay and uh now
we're gonna give you Ken Coleman's book
paycheck to purpose I gave you the the
uh that to listen to now then I I the
first thing we can scratch money
together I don't want you to pay
anything on student loans just don't pay
them right now forget them okay even
though they come up in October just
don't pay them just forget them don't do
the on-ramp though no don't do anything
just ignore them no if you ignore them
it'll put you on the on-ramp and the
interest will accrue okay okay
or whatever it is it'll be zero it'll be
zero for you yeah and just don't don't
you don't worry about paying on the
student loan but pay the minimum you can
get in the same save program it's a
horrible program but at least we keep
playing at the end we're going to pay it
off later but right now I'm minimizing
your outflow because I need you to
gather up a couple thousand dollars for
a car when you got a couple thousand
dollars for a car I want you to walk in
to this Tote The Note dealer and tell
them you talked to
um your financial counselor who said
that they should talk to you about
taking this car back with no
repossession
you've already paid enough on it give
them the keys have them sign a paper you
owe nothing don't give them the keys
unless you get this sign the title over
to them and wash your hands of this car
and walk away they will do that deal
because they do it every day it's their
whole game plan their business model is
overs priced cars over interest cars so
they take them back and resell them
it's how they function and so they
you've already paid enough on it they've
made profit on you and and if they say
we won't do that say my financial
counselor told me I should talk to an
attorney should I do that or do you guys
want to do this
because your financial counselor is me
and I just told you that
right okay so you see what we're doing
we're scaring them because the contract
that they have is probably bustable with
a lawyer but I don't want to spend money
on a lawyer I just want to Bluff these
rednecks into taking the car back
and they take it back no repo and no
deficit they don't get anything on you
and then you go buy two thousand dollar
car with cash
and not from there and not cash not from
them just go go find one in the freaking
Craigslist and it's a garage sale car
who cares okay we're just it's a
short-term thing we're gonna get a
better car in two years anyway we're not
gonna drive this car for very long okay
then you're gonna get the uh the loan
paid off and the credit cards paid off
and uh then we're gonna reach over and
do the same thing with that student loan
with that deficit on that car that car
repo you can settle that thirteen
thousand dollar debt for about two or
three thousand dollars if you call them
up with cash in your pocket and say well
I can settle this right now I'm a single
mom I'm I'm a bankruptcy looking for a
place to happen are you guys sure you'd
want this on the books or do you want to
take three grand a settlement in full
settlement in full is your big word you
use that with a with the uh Tote The
Note dealer when I give you this car
back it's settlement in full and I want
a statement of paper showing that
otherwise I got to go talk to my
attorney and I don't want to do that
please let's just take this deal and be
done with it same thing with these guys
with the repo okay so a couple Grand and
here or there we got you a car and got
rid of most of your debt
right
this is pretty cool yeah I mean I'm
talking I'm talking this time next year
girl you have no debt
oh my gosh that would be amazing
that would be amazing it will be do you
understand what I just told you to do do
you have any questions about it
I do not I wrote everything down okay
and you call us back if you're in the
middle of this and you got a question I
know that's right and if you want me to
call the tote to note guy I will give me
a call and if you need a lawyer if you
need a letter
because my brother's a lawyer I'll get
you one in two seconds girl that could
be fun that could be fun we're helping
her we're doing this we're going to turn
this around this ends with you this
breaks the cycle breaks with you Tiffany
and so hang on we're going to send you
every bit of that stuff this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
Jade Washoe Ramsay personality is my
co-host the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Karen is in Denver to start this
hour hi Karen how are you
and great Dave and Jay thank you so much
for taking my call you're my two
favorite personalities so honored to be
here and also a little bit nervous well
thank you we won't tell the other ones
I might tell Ken we might tell Ken
Kaden I love your turn skinny fat
because I totally identify with that so
my financial aspect not so much food yes
ma'am
how can we help you I'm Dave I'm 62 and
uh debt free except for mortgages I do
have a rental property that's free and
clear and I know how you feel about
selling those to get out of debt
um if I sell this rental property I will
be close to debt free
but I owe the IRS when I saw that
property I've had it 20 years I owe the
IRS about sixty five thousand dollars
so you've never really discussed kind of
um you know your thoughts on
how your desire for us to become debt
free relates to making that big payment
to the IRS are you still good with go
ahead sell that thing pay the IRS and be
done
probably
uh but you know I always just try to
figure out if there's another way to
skin a cat rather than give the
government money right my first goal the
reason I want anybody to be debt free
including me is it's the shortest
distance to wealth
right I get that and stability so it's
not we don't what Dave wants doesn't
really matter but you know where does it
take you is what it what matters so
let's get you there you're 62. you owe
what on your current home
um I owe
um well I made another mistake I bought
a uh property where I'm going to retire
someday and I know that's not something
that you're fond of
um so but I and I owe 3.95 on that
the house I live in I owe 40 on
and then the other rental property I
owe0 on it's free and clear okay the
house you owe forty hours worth of cash
you owe 40 ounce worth what
it's about worth 425. okay and the house
that you owe 395 on is located where
it's in California it's worth 800.
and no one and no one lives too no one
lives in it yes it's
it's oh it's rented
okay so you have two rental properties
one of them you intend to retire in
and when do you intend to retire
it all depends on how you help me with
this question
uh probably within two to three years
okay it'll be partial retirement I'll
never completely retire I'm your age I
don't I'm not ready to yeah retire just
yet yeah okay that's fine I just I'm
trying to figure out the timing on this
no I get it so why California why
Northern California
um actually I have family there and I
would like to be near a body of water
I've been landlocked my entire life and
I'm also tired of the cold okay so this
is uh near the ocean
like Sonoma or something like that oh
that's nice well it's actually Southern
California oh Southern I thought you
said Northern okay that's still very
nice okay I might have because I am a
little nervous that's okay that's okay
um
is it your work is it your work that's
preventing you from what's that yeah
what's that I'm sorry go ahead I just
I'm Mike I'm looking at these numbers
I'm like okay you want to be in Southern
California you've got a rental that's
free and clear that you don't want to
pay the IRS debt on you've got a home
worth 40 000 or that you owe forty
thousand worth 425. you could sell wow
and move down there now and go you could
walk there that's what I'm getting at
well I'm I'm self-employed as a realtor
so oh yeah start a new business
doesn't sound fun okay
all right
um
what's the rental worth
the one that I'm considering selling I
could probably sell it for
um 350 ish
so you've got a million dollars in
equity between these three
it's just the scrambled eggs that's
driving us nuts okay right and I and I
this and how did you come up with a 65
000 gain did you have your tax person
calculate that with your adjusted basis
yeah yeah my CPA okay estimates about
that's about what I'll owe because I've
had it for 20 years
and then that and my income I guess
okay so the big okay concern number one
is debt free is the shortest distance to
wealth concern number two is when you
retire a paid for property is essential
to Stu that you live in is essential for
stability
because it's your largest item and if
you retire at 65 years old and you live
to 95 you've got 30 years of rent
increases you know this is a real estate
agent you do not want to be a renter for
the next 30 Years or a have a mortgage
you want a paid for piece of real estate
that you live in at retirement so these
are our goals so
um you're going to sell this rental it's
just a matter of when
correct I'm going to sell it regardless
because it's 40 years old and it's time
to go back to the universe so I would
end up buying like a little you're gonna
sell it and you're going to sell it when
you move to California and you retire
and you saw the house you live in or
you're going to sell it now and reduce
the mortgage of the pay off the little
forty thousand dollar mortgage to reduce
the other mortgage finish that
California mortgage off when you retire
and sell the house you live in right
so it doesn't matter you're going to
sell this you're not going to keep it 25
years so you know it's just a matter
when you pay the 65 not if right
well I mean I could send 31 exchange it
forever but I'm tired of tenants toilets
and trash quite frankly yeah and I and I
don't and I want your I want your
California house paid off and it's not
paid off with the sale of your personal
residence right
correct so I got to get there and so
since I got to get there I got to sell
the rental
now or when you retire move to
California I'm catching on now I'm still
I'm seeing the scrambled eggs okay so
yeah go and sell it just because you're
going to sell it anyway
okay don't give it away there's no rush
there's no I was going to say if you
don't pay off the 40 if you've got
enough in the bank to pay off your house
no not right this morning you don't have
40 000 bucks laying around
well I do but I can do it Uncle Sam
it's for Uncle Sam
but you don't have you don't have any
you don't have any other non-retirement
Investments laying around you just knock
your house out
correct okay well the seller rental pay
off your house pay that pay the 65 throw
the rest of it at the California then
when you retire sell your house and pay
your house off in California
that ain't bad I guess it's there yeah
took a minute it took a minute part of
me is like okay this first if she's
still got two years she could possibly
let it accumulate a little bit more
value for two years before she sells it
right before she goes to California
I mean it's it's not a lot but it I'm
just saying you know trying to get this
money
[Music]
that would work too she's tired of it
I'm tired she is tired of it
let it go
this is the Ramsay show
oh
[Music]
Jade wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today hey guys if you want to
help us out we'd appreciate it
you know we provide this show as a
podcast as a YouTube show as a radio
show as a TBN show as a free service to
you guys and we appreciate you hanging
out with us we would also appreciate it
if you would click subscribe or click
follow
or share the show just by telling
someone about it or actually cut the
link out email it to your friend and go
Hey listen to this or if you're
particular uh whether it's Spotify or
apple or whatever uh has you know Google
Play if they have a share feature just
click the share feature and you can
share it sometimes it's that easy
sometimes it's your listening on talk
radio and you say hey our local talk
radio station has the Ramsey Show
however you share it we appreciate it
our question of the day is brought to
you by neighborly or hub for Home
Services when you need to make repairs
schedule routine maintenance or find
local help for Home Improvement projects
neighborly is your source for Reliable
home service providers in your area go
to neighborly.com to start your search
all right today's question comes from
Carolyn in Arizona she says when you
have a company match does that count
towards your 15 percent my husband's
work has a three percent match we invest
three percent of his gross into an RSP
which I believe is a Canadian 401k and
the employer contributes three percent
would you say that this is three a three
percent or a six percent contribution
towards our fifteen percent that was a
lot of numbers but basically she's
talking about you know we say in baby
step four that is the time that we want
you to start investing 15 of your gross
income into your retirement okay yeah at
the core of this question Carolyn is
don't ask how little can I invest
because the more you invest the more
money you have ask how can I invest more
that's good don't try to figure out a
way to do less figure I would do more
and then here's the other thing
um if you switch jobs you might get to a
job where there's no match or there's
less match you don't know what what the
future holds and so I think it's always
good to practice the muscle of investing
your 15 of your dollars yeah because the
the match and the pensions and all that
stuff are gravy
that's not money that's not your money
you invest 15 of your money you'll
become wealthy the other gravy will add
to it yeah that's gonna be great and
that's the way to get at this good job
good job Nancy's in Chicago hi Nancy
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hello taking thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
well I want to know what you would
suggest a person would do after the U.S
switches to a digital currency
what should people do Who currently use
cash as a budgeting tool
um well the first thing is I'm going to
suggest you quit me reading so many
articles on the internet
because the U.S is not going to switch
to a hundred percent digital
that's that's the goal people that are
trying to sell gold
on Fox News commercials
that are telling you that
because there's not the U.S here's the
thing Nancy the U.S is about 95 digital
now
almost all of our transactions move a
digit from one account to another now if
you write a check it's a digit it's not
cash if you use a debit card it's a
digit not cash if you have direct
deposit from Social Security or direct
deposit from your work it's not cash
it's a digit those are all digital
transactions if you buy a house and you
wire money from your uh mutual fund to
your closing attorney it's a digit
almost if you buy a car these days I
bought a car that wired money to the
dealer it's a it's a digit I didn't walk
over there with a suitcase of cash and
so the vast majority of transactions
ninety something percent of them
probably not north of 95 percent in the
US are already digital but the is the
U.S going to do away with the Greenback
and not in my lifetime or yours
I sure hope
you're erosion that can't have a credit
card because if I spend money just by
swiping it doesn't register with me and
it'll just evaporate now I'm a person
that has a redneck emergency fund in my
front pocket it's a thousand bucks and
100 bills I've carried it most of my
life in my wallet and so I'm with you
I'm a cash dude and I'm not above
walking up and actually making somebody
learn how to make change for the first
time at the register all day and so um
I'm that guy so I'm right with you but I
I truly don't think we're going to do
away with currency and most of what
you're reading has a Fear Factor to get
you to buy gold or it is some kind of
conspiracy theory stuff on uh
bricks or any of these other things that
are going around just to make us worry
that the entire U.S economy is so
fragile that it's going to collapse
because Russia which isn't their economy
is hardly the size of Texas is is going
to do something Russia's not going to do
spit they don't have the muscle too they
can't even feed their own people and so
you know it just Nancy whatever it is
that you're reading that's causing you
to worry quit reading it
scary it is scary I you know I know
people have different
thoughts around all of that but then
there's parts of me that I think about
there's so many things that have
happened throughout history that we who
are used to those things we look at this
and go yeah it's just part of life but
as it was occurring people were probably
like oh my gosh this is crazy I mean
Cars the cars that we have today there
was a time where that wasn't a thing
flying airplanes like all those things
you could look back and go oh my gosh
there was a time when this wasn't a
thing and maybe who knows and the next
lifetime the Next Generation they will
live in a different sort of currency but
we already have we already are I mean
you think about when I was a kid we the
number of checks we wrote yeah you don't
do that anymore I I in the number of
times you write you see someone write a
check at the grocery store yeah yeah
today I don't do they even take you're
much more likely to say I'm using cash
yeah but my point is we've adapted and
that's that stuff is a slow burn and
before you know it you look up and you
go oh yeah we live lives our lives in a
totally different way
um yeah I just think there's something
besides for the innocent version the the
malevolent version uh the the
love I can't say the evil version is
that there's a conspiracy that the U.S
is going to control the all the digits
and therefore they're going to control
your life well they already do
have all the digits yeah and they don't
control your life with those digits and
so so the question is not the digits
being allowed to control your life
digital money because when you use your
Apple phone or when you use a car a
credit card or a debit card or you
transfer money any other way uh ACH or
anything else it's all digits so when
you do that they already have all of
that that's all available and so and so
far they've not used that to steal our
freedoms no not you know but there's a
commercial I heard it the other day and
then I saw a different thing a write-up
that you know when the US goes digital
you are not going to do transactions and
if they want to cancel you because they
don't like your faith or they don't like
whatever they can just turn off your
ability to do business as if it's like
the the mark of the beast or something
in Revelation okay and it's just I'm
sorry folks I you know
this there may be a mark of the beast
someday but this one's not it there was
a whole thing going around for years
that the credit card was the mark of the
beach oh yeah you had to have a credit
card to do a transaction and then the
last one was with The Foundry quarantine
yeah they had the uh the the uh vaccine
passport yes which kind of was that was
going to be the mark of the beast and at
one point it was when your feet I'm
getting older Beast with marks when your
iPhone scans your face to let you into
the phone it's like they're gonna scan
your eyeball yeah and that's gonna be
yeah now they got your eyeball
so I mean it's it's ever and just don't
get Rachel Nancy I'm glad you didn't
call When Rachel Cruz was here because
she's the conspiracy theorist
extraordinaire and um she would have
joined you in this but no we're I'm not
going to join you so I I'm gonna tell
you honey don't worry I'm not worried
I'm not worried I got big old piles of
cash and I'm not worried about it going
out of style
um like real actual greenbacks so there
we go
yeah you're gonna be fine you're gonna
be fine and uh and gold doesn't solve
this by the way because there's never
been a failed economy or a government
takeover when people exchanged gold bars
I'm gonna run down to Walmart with my
gold bar
since the economy failed and I'm gonna
get me some blue jeans it's just not
going to happen boys and girls not gonna
happen Okay you can't find age since the
Roman Empire
a mod a modern day economy in the last
400 300 years that used actual gold as a
medium of exchange exclusively so these
guys telling you to buy gold because
that's what one of the commercials was
on the digits yeah because Americans are
going digital and you need gold
it's the latest fear to buy gold crap
don't do it this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
Jade wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today I'm Dave Ramsey your host
thank you for being with us Kim is in
Jacksonville Florida hi Kim Welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi Dave hi Jade thank you so much for
taking my call sure um and thank you for
all your work Dave it's changed
everything for me uh but my question is
I sold my house I downsized and bought a
townhouse for me and my daughters and I
was only short about sixteen thousand
dollars so instead of taking a mortgage
I just took a line of credit against my
car
um since it was a lowest lower interest
rate and it was only 16 000. so now I
don't know because it's my last debt
should I tackle this like it's baby step
number two and clear out my um uh
emergency fund or should I look at it
like it's my mortgage even though
technically my mortgage is paid for and
uh continue on the baby steps because
I'm on baby step four currently if I go
that route
I would tackle it as baby step two what
do you have it's like yeah because what
else do you own the car you tack the 16k
to your car that was awesome the car was
paid for yeah the card was paid four so
you're only debt in the whole world is
sixteen thousand dollars do you have it
do you have it laying around anywhere
well it's in my savings account but
that's my well actually only I borrowed
16 but now I've been paying it for the
last five months aggressively so I only
owe eleven thousand dollars how much is
in your emergency fund
seventeen thousand pay it off today and
just stack back up that savings yeah I
agree with Jade what's your income okay
well I just got a raise so I'm up to 57
000. okay so you'll aggressively rebuild
the five thousand six thousand back up
to a good emergency fund within just a
couple of months okay that's what I was
thinking I mean I was ready I called the
bank I asked my lady I'm like hey I
think I'm ready to pay it off and then I
thought well maybe I should you know
keep that emergency and work at you know
baby step number four because I'm not at
15 right now
um so yeah that's what I wanted to call
I wanted to see if it was if it was uh
you know a little bit more money or
something I might slow down and make it
six or something but I I think it's this
there's a tremendous amount to be said
for cleanliness
okay I like that this is just clean your
life is very clean your baby step seven
now we just rock and roll on the
Investments as soon as we get the
emergency fund done right
right right get that and because I'm
only at like four or five percent right
now with Investments so I have to have
to work on that yeah you know Jack that
as high as you can possibly jacket after
you get the house paid off the emergency
fund in place okay okay all right thank
you so very much I appreciate it thank
you we appreciate you calling that was
good that was good she kind of just
jumped back a step she'll do two three
and four and on to the races that's good
not sure I would have done it that way
but now that we're there that's the plan
Jared is in Minnesota hi Jared how are
you
hey Dave
how can we help
yeah uh my wife and I
um are going to be expecting a baby in
March congratulations we are trying
thank you uh we are trying to find
something a little bit more suitable
um for living
um and with the high costs of rent we
were thinking about potentially getting
a house
um so that the mortgages uh usually
roughly about the same or a little less
do you guys have any debt
yeah I'm currently a student I'm in my
last year of school
um and I've had to pay my way through
and I'm about 61 in student loans and
then she had a car that she had bought
after she graduated
um a few years ago which is at 18.
what's your degree in
my degree is math education what are you
going to do teach
yep okay what what will a math teacher
make
um usually starting it depends on the
the school district anywhere from uh 40
to 50.
what about your wife
uh she currently makes 51. okay and
she's done with school salary
yeah she's done the school and she's
she's working currently and what is her
profession
uh art teacher so a couple of teachers
okay
um look congratulations on the baby
coming I'm excited for you guys I want
you to have a house I want you to have
all those things but I want you to have
them the right way so they don't have
you right
um so first first things first hey I'm
just gonna walk the baby steps on this
are you familiar with that at all
a little bit okay so this is going to be
the fastest as Dave would say the
cleanest way uh for you to not only pay
off your debt save up the money you need
and eventually build wealth so there's a
framework here
um and it involves paying off your debt
first before purchasing a home and the
reason for that is a your income right
now is tied up in your student it's
going to be tied up in your student
loans it's tied up in your car
and we want to free that up so that
you're able to save the down payment you
want you're able to get the house that
you truly want right
make sense
yeah rent is a great deal
short term it's a horrible deal long
term
so I agree with you you don't want to do
it long term but short term you if you
buy a house with this much debt you have
to buy an extra bedroom for Sallie Mae
um
because you you know she's still living
with you and you need to kick the old
woman out before you buy a house because
it's going to strain you heat and air
will go out the water heater will go out
in the roof will leak the first week you
move in this house with a bunch of debt
don't do that you're gonna get yourself
in a pinch you're a broke college
student brand new married brand new baby
on the way you're at the broke end of
life yeah do you have anything it's the
most broke you'll ever be right now
it'll be nothing but better from here
you know better incomes from here a
better situation from here so renting
for the next little while uh is the
babies don't take up much room they're
small and renting for a little while
while you guys get your mess cleaned up
that you've made and then have a solid
foundation to buy the home will be a
blessing for you and not a curse if
you'll do that it is not popular among
your friends for me to tell you that but
I don't really care what your friends
think they're broke and you don't want
to take Financial advice from broke
people so uh the the the risk that you
are adding mathematically to your life
by adding a house to a new baby into a
big old pile of debt This spells stress
true that anxiety problems in
relationships don't do it please keep
your life calm and simple get out both
of you get a job both of you work your
tail off smile about the time that we
had to eat broke people food and drive
broke people cars yeah and you'll
remember that Sharon and I had those
days Jade and Sam had those days when
you're first getting married that's the
normal thing that's right and by the way
if you're sitting on a big chunk of
money because you have money from the
wedding or money from graduation throw
it out the debt throw it at the debt
clean it up list your debt smallest to
largest and dump them in that area we'll
give you a baby gift Financial Peace
University we're going to give your baby
a gift we're going to teach his mama and
daddy how to handle money and if you'll
follow the stuff I teach you in the that
and that Rachel and George and deloney
teach you in Financial Peace University
you will become wealthy if you don't
follow it you will stump your toe
stumble and struggle and look like most
people looking good and broke and buying
crap you can't afford with money you
don't have to impress people you don't
even really like and so it is a normal
good dad
unction to go by your new child a home
thank you for being a good dad but
you're going to resist that in order to
be a great dad that's right and a dad
that delays pleasure children do what
feels good adults devise a plan and
follow it so hang on we'll get you guys
signed up for Financial Peace University
and you two go through that together as
a young married couple it'll be the best
thing you've ever done I promise you and
if you don't I'll give you all your
money back oh wait a minute you didn't
pay for it so there you go I'll take
some of that money back
that was our old back in the day we had
Financial Peace University we had a
money back guarantee we said if you go
to all nine classes you won't want your
money back if you don't go to all nine
classes we won't give you your money
back but if you'll go to all nine
classes you won't ever ask for a refund
and never had a single person ask for a
refund so there you go good it's a great
question
um yeah you just got to prove attendance
and all nine classes and that you hated
it and that we ripped you off nah nobody
ever got mad at anybody for getting them
out of debt
that's right you're too much fun this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
our scripture today James 1 4 let
perseverance finish its work so that you
may be mature and complete not lacking
anything
and Sullivan said people seldom see the
halting and painful steps by which the
most insignificant success is achieved
I love it Gina is with us in San Antonio
hi Gina welcome to the Ramsay show
can we help
long time listener big fan
um so I have been married 19 years uh 55
years old I am going for a divorce we're
probably towards the end of
unfortunately a pretty contentious
divorce uh we have been blessed with a
lot of assets and a very good income
um and my question is you know because I
I was not in charge of our finances when
we were married my my former husband
handed all that and I have to say he did
a great job
um my question is what debt should I
prioritize to pay off once the divorce
is final
oh my I'm sorry mm-hmm
that's really hard well a friend of mine
that does divorce counseling says that
divorce turns a marriage into a business
transaction
and so first and foremost let me clarify
uh what you're going to end up with and
why
um are you who's taking the home
primary homeless already been sold and
we've each already purchased new homes
okay good that's good news so that got
rid of that problem is there any Co debt
that both of you are on
yes sir we have three investment homes
that have 50 Equity we have a SBA loan
that we had to take out during covid of
150 000.
and
um we have a vehicle that we owe about
26 000 that my former husband will be
taking okay
the divorce court does not have the
power to remove you from those debts
it has the power to assign the debts to
one of you but if the let's say your
husband's taking the car it has your
name on the debt if he doesn't pay it it
comes back on you
okay so you have what's called a
contingent liability as if you co-signed
on those so all of those deaths that you
mentioned are real concerning
um because I got a feeling the SBA loan
is a business loan obviously and it's
he's probably running that business it
sounds like
we actually are both 50 50 owners on our
business we have a business together as
well so there's a lot of pieces it's a
big web which is why this has been going
on since January so what's happening
with the business who's going to end up
with it
well he's going to maintain that
business at LLC
um I we are in the same business uh in
the meetings and events business and we
each have our own clients he'll maintain
the LLC that's in existence and I will
establish a new one okay and you'll take
your clients and go on with your life
okay but the SBA loan is in both of your
names
yes sir now he's offered to take to take
it to the debts but I don't know exactly
um how that like you said I'm not saying
the same thing it has your name on it he
can take it but if he doesn't refinance
it and get your name off of it it
doesn't pay it for some reason let's say
he gets in trouble in business or gets
an IRS lien or something that that even
he didn't see coming okay you're going
to end up holding the bag on these
investment properties this SBA loan this
car if he's supposed to take them
unquote quote unquote so
um and divorce attorneys don't do a good
job of explaining that to people
so they oftentimes they oftentimes just
split things up and they go well he's
got the car and I got this investment
house and he's still on the investment
house that you got you know and uh he's
still got you know if you screw it up
he's he's baked then so uh you said
there's a lot of assets yeah what kind
of cash do you guys have yeah really
well um so we we did make a um a nice
proceeds from the sale of our primary
home we split those that was about
328 000 each okay so those those monies
were um split and they were there's a
legal word for them partitioned okay so
normally the lawyers advise not to buy
new homes in the middle of a divorce
right community property but we signed
documents that the funds were
partitioned of that 328 000.
um the loan I re I was able to get by
just barely
um only allowed me to put down 140 000
so I still have the rest of that cash
untouched in a bank account that I would
like to put down towards my current home
I also received a large inheritance
unfortunately it's been a heck of a
couple of years both my parents passed
in the last two years sorry about that
yeah that's still
um I received an inheritance of 528 000
um and it's in a separate account as
well untouched it's just been sitting
there
um Let me let me let me propose
something really weird it may throw a
monkey wrench in the middle of your
negotiations
I I would propose selling the three
rental houses paying off the SBA and
paying off the house and splitting the
cash I love that
paying off the car I'm sorry paying off
the car paying off the SBA loan getting
rid of the three rentals and then you
just walk over the poly cash he walks
away with a pile of cash
yeah because what would have been the
plan with the rentals well
I'm guessing you guys were getting ready
to split those up weren't you
yeah now we keep dancing around like
how's this going to work and we can only
remove each other from title and exactly
that's what I'm talking about you can
get off a title but you can't get off
the mortgage same thing with the stupid
SBA loan you can go open your own LLC
but you're still on the stupid loan for
175k
cleanliness here it is again yeah that's
been the and so I it's um yeah yeah I I
think you're both setting up a very sad
uh reason but you're both setting up a
new dream
you're you're 20 years from now future
is a completely different picture than
it was five years ago
right and it doesn't involve an SBA loan
and it doesn't involve him having a car
payment with your name on it and it
doesn't involve three rental houses
the only way I would keep those rental
properties is if you refinanced them and
got each other's names off of them
okay it's because it's gonna bite you
I've done that I've done this for 30
years it's gonna come back and bite you
it may be 10 years it may be uh five
years from now you want to remarry and
you all want to do something and this
stupid SBA loan has got your name on it
and it keeps you you and your new
husband from getting a house
yeah this is gonna as long as you keep
all this around it's going to keep each
of you from having the fresh start that
you want yeah that you need it's your
best shot at healing is the complete
separation so I don't know if I can talk
you guys and the lawyers into this but
man if it was me I would want to be uh
you know shake the dust off my feet man
I'd want to be clear a couple stupid
rental houses to be done with the SBA
loan the car loan and him yeah that's
not and you get all the cash you get
your half of the cash net
hey it's kind of a no-brainer then the
only thing we got to split up 401ks or
whatever's laying out there there's
nothing else left y'all already split
the home
right right you're gonna end up walking
away with over a million dollars cash in
the debt free house you're living in
well uh I would pay that's this house
off so that's my next question because
yeah you pay that house off but you got
528 000 laying there now you could do
that and you've got another 200 000
almost laying there from the from the
partition and you got the equities from
the rentals I don't even know what they
are minus the debts I mean the prices of
the rentals minus the debts minus the
taxes due because of the sale minus the
SBA loan minus paying off his car and
then the only thing left is divide up
that cash in the 401ks against each
other that ain't bad
it's just really clean it's clean
walking and if you want to buy some
rentals you know after you've finished
crying and being mad and all the stuff
that goes with this get our own then go
get you a rental later but who you know
you got plenty of money you're you're
both going to walk out this millionaires
I'm guessing that's what it sounds like
and I know you are for sure with the
inheritance uh and you know and you've
got a good client base you're confident
in your your career steps you know you
got a good solid place for healing and a
fresh start I'm so sorry yeah but man
that's a lot of loss I really wouldn't
try to keep my finances in the past
while I'm trying to live a future I
don't know why the lawyers wouldn't
suggestions are they just bozos or they
don't take into consideration these
contingent liabilities because they
don't have to deal with it five years
from now I do when they come to me yeah
I got to deal with it when it screws up
and goes sideways
that puts us out of the Ramsey Show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]